there's a big theme here because you
come from the mecca of robotics which is
carnegie mellon university robotics like
for all the people i've interacted with
that come from there or just from
you know the world experts at robotics
they don't
they would never build something like
cosmo yeah and so where did that come
from
so the simplicity it came from this
combination of a team that we had it was
it was quite cool because like we and by
the way you ask anybody that's like
experienced in the like kind of you know
toy entertainment space you'll never
sell a product over 99 um that was
fundamentally false and we believed it
to be false it was because experience
had to kind of you know meet the mark
and so we pushed past that amount but
there was a pressure where the higher
you go the more seasonal you become and
the tougher it becomes and so on the
cost side we very quickly partnered up
with some previous contacts that we
worked with where just as an example one
our head of mechanical engineering um
was one of the earliest heads of
engineering at logitech and has a
billion units of consumer products in
circulation that he's worked on yeah so
like crazy low-cost high-volume consumer
product experience we had a really great
mechanical engineering team and just a
very practical mindset where we were not
going to compromise on feasibility in
the market in order to chase something
that would be enabler and we pushed a
huge amount of expectations onto the
software team where yes we're going to
use cheap
noisy motors and sensors but we're gonna
fix it in the um on the software side
then we found on the design and
character side there was a faction that
was more from like a game design
background that thought that it should
be very games driven cosmo where you
create a whole bunch of games
experiences and it's all about like game
mechanics
and then there was um a fashion which my
my co-founder and i the most involved in
this like really believed in which was
character driven and the argument is
that you will never compete with what
you can do virtually from a game
standpoint but you actually on the
character side put this into your
wheelhouse and put it more towards your
advantage because a physical character
has a massively
higher impact uh physically than
virtually this is okay just on that
because this is so brilliant when i uh
for people who don't know cosmo
plays games with you
but there's also a depth of character
and i actually when i was
you know playing with it
i wondered
exactly what is the compelling aspect of
this because to me obviously i'm i'm
biased but to me the character i get
what i enjoyed most honestly or what got
me to return to it is the character
that's right but that's that's a
fascinating discussion of uh
you're right ultimately you cannot
compete
on the
quality of the gaming experience
restrictive the physical world is just
too restrictive and uh you don't have a
graphics engine it's like all this but
on the character side we uh and clearly
we moved in that direction is like kind
of the the the winning path and um we
partnered up with this uh really we
immediately like went towards pixar and
carlos bainer he was um one of like had
been in pixar for nine years he'd worked
on tons of the movies including wally
and others and just immediately kind of
spoke the language and it just clicked
on how you think about that like kind of
magic and drive and then he we built out
a team uh you know with him as like a
really kind of prominent kind of driver
of this with different types of
backgrounds and animators and character
developers where um
we put these constraints on the team but
then got them to really try to create
magic despite that and we converged on
this system that was at the overlap of
character and the character ai
that where if you imagine the
dimensionality of emotions happy
sad angry surprised confused uh um
scared like you think of these extreme
emotions
we almost like kind of put this
challenge to kind of populate this
library of responses on how do you show
the extreme
response that like goes to the extreme
spectrum on angry or frustrated or
whatever and and so that gave us a lot
of intuition and learnings and um and
then we started parameterizing them
where it wasn't just a fixed recording
but they were parameterized and had
randomness to them where you could have
infinite permutations of happy and
surprised and so forth
and then we had a behavioral engine that
took the context from the real world
and would interpret it and then create
kind of probability mappings on what
sort of responses you would have that
actually made sense and so
if cosmos saw you for the first time in
a day um he'd be really surprised and
happy in the same way that the first
time you walk in and like your toddler
sees you they're so happy but they're
not gonna be that happy for the entirety
of your next two hours but like you have
this like spike in response or if you
leave him alone for too long he gets
bored and starts causing trouble and
like nudging things off the table um or
if you beat him in a game um the most
enjoyable emotions are him getting
frustrated and grumpy to a point where
our testers and our customers would be
like
i had to let him win because i don't
want him to be upset and uh and so you
start to like create this feedback loop
where you see how powerful those
emotions are and just to give you an
example something as simple as eye
contact um you don't think about it in a
movie just like it kind of happens like
you know camera angles and so forth um
but that's not really a prominent source
of interaction
what happens when a physical character
like cosmo when he makes eye contact
with you um
it built universal kind of connection
kids all the way through adults um and
it was truly universal it was not like
people stopped caring after 10 12 years
old
and so uh we started doing experiments
and we found something as simple as
increasing the amount of eye contact
like the amount of times in a minute
that he'll look over for your approval
to like kind of make eye contact just by
i think doubling it we increase the play
time engagement by 40
like you see these sort of like kind of
interactions where you build that
empathy and and so we studied pets we
studied um virtual characters there's
like a lot of times actually dogs are
one of the perfect most perfect uh um
influencers behind these sort of
interactions and what we realized is
that the games were not there to
entertain you the games were to create
context to bring out the character and
if you think about the types of games
that you know that you played they're
relatively simple but they were always
once to create scenarios of either
tension or winning or losing or surprise
or whatever the case might be and they
were purely there to just like create
context to where an emotion could feel
intelligent and not random
and in the end it was all about the
character
so yeah there's so many
elements to play with here so you said
dogs what lessons do we draw from cats
who don't seem to give a damn about you
is that just another character is this
this
it's just another character and so you
you could almost like in the early
aspirations we thought it would be
really incredible if you had a diversity
of characters where you almost help
encourage which direction it goes just
like in a role-playing game
um and you had uh like think of like the
you know seven dwarfs sort of and uh um
and initially we even thought that it
would be amazing if like you know
they're like
you know like their characters actually
help them be have strengths and
weaknesses and some you know like
whatever they end up doing like some are
scared some are
you know uh arrogant some are uh
you know super warm and like kind of
friendly and in the end we focused on
one because it made it very clear that
hey we got to build out enough depth
here because you're
kind of trying to expand
it's almost like how long can you
maintain a fiction that this character
is alive um to where the person's
explorations don't hit a boundary um
which happens almost immediately with
with typical toys um and you know even
with video games uh how long can we
create that immersive experience to
where you expand the boundary and one of
the things we realized is that you're um
just way more forgiving when something
has a personality and it's physical
that is the key uh that unlocks
uh robotics interacting you know in the
physical world more generally is that
that uh the
when you have a when you don't have a
personality and you make a mistake as a
robot the stupid robot made a mistake
why is it not perfect when you have a
character and you make a mistake you
have empathy and it becomes endearing
and you're way more forgiving and that
was the key that was like i think goes
far far beyond entertainment
you